servus erst jetzt herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ihr seht es ist heute
alles wissen alles im setup her wenn man
max am pc und heute mit weniger in jump
league und wir spielen vorsichtig muss
jetzt wirklich aufpassen denn wir
spielen heute die teller voll stand
schon wie nie wir nehmen das hier first
try out nein das ist das spiel das wir
spielen nämlich wer runter fällt muss
stehen beim bis zum ende der runde
sobald einer runterfällt ist vorbei für
den leute mit wo man in ober einem blog
auf den unteren auf den oberen also
erstmal double jumpen auf der ersten
eisblock und dann vom ersten eisblock
runter auf den zweiten und dann direkt
weiter hatte durch springen auf den
anderen
leute leute ich hab die paranoia ohne
witz mein leben erst nein nein nein nein
okay es ist richtig hassen würde wo ich
einmal diesen sprung passiven erst
richtig du hast einfach so module wo du
weißt okay wenn ich jetzt nicht richtig
glück gehabt dann falle ich hier runter
auf jeden fall man aber jetzt echt ein
paar ekliger easy modell wie am anfang
ich bin rückwärts vom blog runter
gelaufen aber ich auch verpacken ich
sortiere dann schaut man inventar fürs
finale ich habe alles so gut ich lauf
und dann rückwärts runter wo bist du
module 6
ja okay also weniger als 45 prozent
stehen geblieben wir lassen es mal die
zeit verstreichen und springen direkt
aus death match akkurat wie gut wir uns
mit diesen karten equipment schlagen
können so leute wissen das match dort
drückte die daumen ich merke dass der
ingame sound vieles laut ist kann
sterben vor
aber ich würde euch die tage des der
abgestaubt und hat der andere täter kann
der typ response mich ab gestoppt also
was ist eigentlich mit diesen leuten die
immer im schnieken sprinten sind dass
hacker es ist ein bug anzeige back
anzeige backen dachten wir schon okay
gut also ich hab mir dann eingeholt ja
du hast dir das so richtig ist da leider
um ist einer von der leyen an ich kämpfe
gegen zwei leute das mega der abfahrt
gar keinen fall machen du musst jetzt
echt ein ich kann nichts machen weil ich
gerade mit einem ganzen bus und prüfung
mitgespielt das lustig wie dem spaß dran
aufpassen
du bist besser waffe kann ich nur ins
netz
bessere warum schon wieder ich kenne die
ganze gingen selben typ man bekomme was
aus dem sein leben an der hastig ich
suche ein leben hast du oder ich brauche
dich direkt wenn du bist ausgeflogen
ich habe immer leid ich hasse dieses
gefühl werde europa was tipps hinten
angerannt kommt ne regina hat vertritt
nur ein leben aber ehrlich ich bin
half-life nicht so lies nicht half life
3 sondern einfach nur half life 3 lebt
sagt immer ich wollte mich durch mein
leben ich liebe das ist erstklassig zu
platzieren
nein ich selbst sein okay ja gut aber
ich war ja gut ich war okay
da wir aber nicht wie gegangen aber er
kann sich wieder vorrang seine gut ich
kann überraschen ich kann überraschen
ok ersten hat noch ein leben hat ein
lehman brothers seien die leute kennt
das prozedere wenigsten verlinkt falls
sie dennoch nicht kennen sollte was ich
stark bezweifle
jack trotzdem ab und bis zum nächsten
video